[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
total saftigen zitronenkuchen er besteht
aus einem rührteig und gedrängt habe ich
ihn auch noch ich zeige euch später noch
womit und getobt habe ich ihn mit einem
leckeren zitronen guss
[Musik]
zuallererst zeige ich euch die zutaten
für den teig wir benötigen mehr
speisestärke außerdem zucker neutrales
öl butter milch wer mag kann natron
verwenden und backpulver außerdem
vanille extrakt oder vanille zucker und
zitronensaft
[Musik]
zuallererst werden die eier zusammen mit
dem zucker in der küchenmaschine etwa
fünf minuten lang cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
wer keine küchenmaschine hat kann das
ganze selbstverständlich auch mit dem
handrührgerät machen
[Musik]
nachdem alles schön cremig ist geben wir
die flüssigen zutaten mit hinzu also
buttermilch und auch den zitronensaft
[Musik]
falls ihr eine bio zitrone habt dann
nimmt auf jeden fall noch den abrieb
davon das schmeckt auch super lecker in
kuchen
[Musik]
nun wird das ganze gerade so
untergerührt bis sich alles verbunden
hat und vergisst auch euren vanille
extrakt nicht wer vanille zucker
verwendet der kann das ganz am anfang
mit hin zu geben wenn er auch den weißen
zucker mit hinzu gibt
nun geben wir die trockenen zutaten mit
hinzu und an der stelle gebe ich natron
und backpulver bereits zur speisestärke
und sieht das dann in den tag hinein
[Musik]
da der zitronenkuchen schon säure
enthält durch den zitronensaft und auch
durch die buttermilch können wir hier
ganz einfach mit dazu geben damit der
kuchen besser aufgeht der kein natron
hat oder das nicht verwenden möchte der
kann es auch ganz einfach durch
backpulver ersetzen
[Musik]
nachdem auch das mehl komplett hinein
gelegt wurde rühren wir alles noch
einmal um so lange bis sich alles
miteinander verbunden hat
[Musik]
hier seht ihr die konsistenz des teigs
und nun kann er gebacken werden
[Musik]
den teig fülle ich jetzt in meine mit
backpapier ausgelegte springform die hat
übrigens einen durchmesser von 26 cm
dann wird er bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen für
30 minuten in der unteren einschub
leiste gebacken
nach dem backen wir der zitronenkuchen
noch getränk damit er noch saftiger wert
und hierfür pressen wir uns zuallererst
den saft einer zitrone aus
[Musik]
dann geben wir noch lauwarme milch und
honig mit hinzu wer keinen honig fern
ist der kann auch die menge ganz einfach
durch puderzucker ersetzen
[Musik]
dann wird alles gut miteinander verrührt
so lange bis der honig geschmolzen ist
[Musik]
der zitronenkuchen durfte nach dem
backen etwa 15 minuten abkühlen er ist
also noch lauwarmen rum jetzt schneide
ich oben noch den vogel ab den kann man
meistens leider nicht vermeiden denn wir
haben natron und backpulver drin und
deshalb geht er so schön auf die reste
werden dann einfach so nebenbei
vernascht und jetzt geht es weiter mit
unserer trinke hierfür einfach den ring
wieder drumherum geben und dann stechen
wir mit einem zahnstocher zb in den teig
ein die mitte müsst ihr dafür nicht mehr
ein stechen die haben ja schon
aufgeschnitten sondern eher noch den
rand darüber kommt dann die vollständige
zitronen tränke und der kuchen kann
vollständig auskühlen
[Musik]
nach dem kühlen geht es weiter mit dem
leckeren zitronen gustin bereiten wird
zu aus puderzucker und zitronensaft
[Musik]
damit wir einen dickflüssigen guss
erhalten geben wir immer etwas
zitronensaft zum puderzucker und rühren
dann um zu sehen wie die konsistenz ist
nachdem der bus dann ungefähr so eine
konsistenz hat ist er fertig und wir
können weitermachen mit dem dekorieren
[Musik]
der zitronenkuchen durfte in der
zwischenzeit schön auskühlen und nun
gebe ich ihnen mit hilfe eines torten
ritters auf eine tortenplatte
[Musik]
damit wir ein schönes finish erhalten
geben wir den bus auf den kuchen und
lassen den an den seiten herunter
fließen
[Musik]
der bus muss dann nur noch fest werden
und das geht superschnell und dann könnt
ihr den kuchen auch schon anschneiden
[Musik]
für mich ist das der saftigsten
zitronenkuchen den es gibt und ihr müsst
ihn unbedingt mal ausprobieren
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt auch diesen leckeren
zitronenkuchen nach machen möchtet und
euch vom geschmack selbst überzeugen
lassen möchte dann schaut mal unten in
die infobox da stehen wir immer die
genauen mengenangaben und ich freue mich
wie immer sehr über fotos auf instagram
mit dem hashtag egis kitchen
[Musik]
falls ihr jedoch lust habt auf einen
total saftigen mohnkuchen oder eine
leckere schokolade tat dann bleibt bis
zum schluss dran ich verlinke euch beide
videos in der end card und ich freue
mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch
wieder einschaltet
[Musik]